bonjour à tous
quand vous achetez une machine à laver
ou un téléphone portable
en êtes-vous véritablement propriétaire
acheter un produit vous autorise style à
détruire l'ensemble de ses constituants
sans vous soucier d'impact
environnemental que ça implique
le jour du dépassement vous savez ce
jour à partir duquel on a épuisé
l'ensemble des ressources que la terre
peut renouveler dans l'année et on
commence à puiser de façon irréversible
dans ses réserves et bien pour un
français
ce jour était en 1970 à fin décembre
en 2000 il était à fin septembre
puis en 2010 est animée et cette année
ce jour est à mi mars ça c'est du côté
des réserves
de l'autre côté de notre cycle de
consommation
on accumule les déchets sans
véritablement se soucier du fait que les
produits qu'on jette et leurs
constituants pourrait parfois être
utilisé tel quel pour fabriquer de
nouveaux produits ou pour en réparer des
anciens on va crouler sous une montagne
de déchets tels molly
par ailleurs
par épuisement des ressources
un grand nombre des innovations qui font
notre confort au quotidien
vont nous être bientôt indisponibles
l'ensemble de ce cycle
génère annuellement 50 % de plus de co2
que la terre ne peut absorber en faisant
d'ailleurs l'actualité ces derniers
jours sur les problèmes bioclimatique
on ne peut plus continuer comme ça
alors que faire
on peut pas pointer du doigt une raison
ou une industrie particulière
pour être à l'échelle des enjeux il faut
que la solution implique l'ensemble de
nos habitudes de consommation et
également la plupart d'entre nous
alors notre système productif
a commencé à s'organiser selon le
principe de l'économie circulaire
ce que je vous propose c'est d'aller
plus loin avec l'économie sphérique
d'économie circulaire est souvent
réduite à un recyclage des déchets
d'idées de l'économie sphérique et de
créer des boucles de valeur
tout au long du cycle d'utilisation de
nos produits et leurs constituants en
intensifiant le partage et les nouveaux
usages
ces boucles de l'économie sphérique sont
autant d'opportunités d'optimisation des
ressources et de création de valeur avec
des nouveaux services
alors aujourd'hui les bases sont déjà là
premièrement
on observe une appétence pour des
modèles d'usagé par rapport à des
modèles basés sur la propriété notamment
chez les jeunes générations
personnellement mes enfants n'ont pas de
voiture certes urbain
mais il utilise blabla car ou hubert
même type de comportement avec les
résidences secondaires et à bienne be
deuxièmement les technologies digitales
et les réseaux logistiques sont
également disponibles et puis enfin il
ya des nouveaux modèles d'affaires qui
se met en place à l'initiative des start
up mais pas que comme nous le verrons
quelques exemples vous connaissez sans
doute gym ted ou leboncoin qui vous
permet de rechercher des personnes
intéressé par vos articles qui même vous
ouvre vous offre maintenant des options
logistique pour organiser tout ça mais
sans possibilités de valorisation des
constituants ou de réparation
vous pouvez vous tourner vers le tri
sélectif pour récupérer les constituants
parfois c'est partiale et puis il n'ya
pas de valorisation à votre niveau et
pas de réparation non plus vous pouvez
vous tourner vers des rippeurs café ou
décathlon seconde vie qui vont vous
proposer des réparations mais sans
possibilité d'avoir accès à d'autres
objets pour d'autres usages
darty va plus loin en acceptant la
réparation de produits d'autres
fabricants emmaüs peut récupérer vos
objets mais pas tous ont la possibilité
de les valoriser d'autres exode autre
exemple comme mattel par exemple vous
permet de recycler ou de recycler vos
poupées barbie ou voiture dinky toys
mais tous ces petits mondes s'ignorent
car ils procèdent de logique économique
souvent différente les initiatives sont
locales
si l'hôte et sans passerelle et le
parcours utilisateur est parfois très
complexes
ce que
peut apporter
un changement pour permettre cette
économie sphérique c'est l'idée de la
consigne alors une consigne qui va plus
loin que ce que certains d'entre vous
ont connu avec leurs bouteilles de lait
ou de bière une consigne 3.0 la consigne
universel
alors la consigne universel
ça sera simple comme une appli
projetons nous un petit peu pour
comprendre comment ça peut fonctionner
je peux reprendre l'exemple de la
machine à laver un que j'ai cité trois
fois en introduction
cette machine à laver vous la posséder
vous avez un couple qui va s'agrandir
vous cherchez une machine à laver de
plus grande capacité
l'application va d'abord vous permettre
de scanner votre produit
documenter son état
avoir accès à l'historique d'utilisation
et puis rechercher des acquéreurs
potentiels ou plutôt des gens qui
pourraient en avoir l'usagé
puis également identifié d'autres
personnes qui ont l'usagé d'un produit
qui correspond à vos nouveaux besoins
une machine de plus grande taille
l'application vous met en relation
vous offre des options logistique un
dépôt un point relais où le passage de
la poste ou autres services de
messagerie qui va venir prendre soin de
votre
équipement à chaque fois en monétisant
respectivement les consignes respectives
des appareils échangés
dans d'autres cas de figure vous pouvez
avoir accès à un service de réparation
de mise de mise à jour des programmes de
votre machine
voire de recyclage à chaque fois en
monétisant la consigne du produit ou les
consignes des constituants élémentaires
donc on voit que cette comptine
universelle c'est un porte monnaie
virtuel qui vous permet d'avoir plus de
pouvoir d'achat oups réflexe
consumériste plus de pouvoir d'usagé
ce pouvoir d' usage vous le visualiser
avec en temps réel un état de l'ensemble
des consignes des produits dont vous
avez usages et quand vous allez échanger
ou transférer votre produit ou le
recycler et dans votre portefeuille va
refléter les chances de consignes et
pouvoir valoriser le
nouvel état de vaud de vos produits
alors ce portefeuille virtuel nous
sensibilise également sur les composants
et la valeur ajoutée qui sont
incorporées dans nos produits du
quotidien donc il ya un effet
pédagogique
autour de tout ça
qu'est ce que on peut imaginer avec
cette consigne universal ont d'abord sa
grande fonction ça va être d'être le
lien entre les différentes initiatives
de l'économie sphérique dont j'ai parlé
en permettant de mettre en réseau ces
initiatives on va densifier massifier
les échanges tous ensemble et offrir une
profondeur d'utilisation qui reflète nos
besoins du quotidien
alors l'impact va être triple
d'abord la préservation des ressources
en les valorisant impact écologique
deuxièmement un impact économique plus
de pouvoir d'achat oups encore une fois
plus de pouvoir d'usagé et puis enfin un
impact sociétal
avec cette économie sphérique on crée de
l'emploi on développe des compétences
la réparation c'est trois fois plus
d'emplois que le recyclage qui est
lui-même 50 fois plus d'emplois que
l'incinération donc cet ego de miss fury
qu'à un véritable gisement pour l'emploi
enfin l'économie sphérique est synonyme
d'innovation
j'y suis particulièrement attachée en
tant qu'entrepreneur innovation au
service
du bien commun et pour préserver
l'environnement je vais vous donner un
exemple
c'est celui de michelin
fleet services iis
historiquement michelin gagné de
l'argent en vendant des pneus en
l'occurrence les pneus de camions
qui durait à peu près 300 mille
kilomètres plus de pneus vendus plus de
chiffre d'affaires mais également plus
de matières consommer et plus de déchets
produits avec business avec michelin
flitzer des six
michelin facture à son client les
kilomètres parcourus donc l'idée n'est
plus de maximiser la vente de pneus mais
d'optimiser la durée de vie des pneus
pour pouvoir
faire le plus grand nombre de kilomètres
possibles en l'occurrence avec des
rechapage de pneus
le résultat est que les pneus doit dure
trois fois plus longtemps il ya beaucoup
moins d'énergie de matières consommer
beaucoup moins de déchets générés mais
également une économie pour le client
d'environ 20% par rapport au modèle
précédent
donc on voit que tout le monde est
gagnant et en particulier
l'environnement alors qu'est ce qui
reste à faire pour mettre en place cette
économie ferrique et la consigne
universelle qui va avec
alors premièrement les technologies
alors on l'a vu
les technologies digitales pour la mise
en relation des différents protagonistes
sont la lie aux ti pour arriver à
identifier les objets documenter leur
état est disponible la blog shane pour
la traçabilité est là aussi toutes les
briques technologiques sont disponibles
le deuxième point c'est la logistique et
bien les réseaux logistiques sont là et
généralement surcapacitaire
le troisième point c'est l' architecture
financière il faut adosser cette
consigne universel à une carte de crédit
il faut également utiliser un système
qui bloque shane avec des jetons
d'utilisation par exemple à bloc chains
son mode token comme on dit
pour pouvoir assurer les transactions
financières et leurs leur degré de
confiance et puis créer un fonds pour
pouvoir rendre l'argent tout ceci est
possible
ce qu'il faut également faire c'est
organiser des filières de réparation et
former les réparateurs et enfin et c'est
probablement le plus important il faut
mettre en réseau l'ensemble des acteurs
les distributeurs les producteurs les
réparateurs les pouvoirs publics et les
associations
pour densifier ces échanges et permettre
d'atteindre une taille critique
l'utilisation des objets du quotidien
pour répondre à nos besoins
alors ce que je
propose concrètement
c'est de faire un pilote
au niveau des acteurs de notre
écosystème du territoire paris saclay
avec des distributeurs des producteurs
des pouvoirs publics des associations
pour tester ce principe de la consigne
universal localement on tirer les
enseignements et pouvoir par réplication
du pattern étendre un niveau plus global
l'idée
en attendant on peut tous agir on peut
agir en tant que consommateur en
privilégiant les modèles de partage en
privilégiant la réparation et
éventuellement le recyclage on peut agir
en tant que concepteur d'objets
en s'appuyant sur l'éco-conception et en
prévoyant dès la conception de l'objet
l'ingénierie de la réparation
on peut agir en tant qu'entrepreneur en
privilégiant à des modèles de
consommation des modèles plutôt axés sur
le service et le partage
générateur de beaucoup de valeur et puis
enfin en tant que pouvoir public on peut
agir par ces politiques d'achat par la
normalisation
également par une fiscalité incitative
sur les flux d'économie sphérique
le mahatma gandhi nous suggérait
d'incarner le changement qu'on veut voir
dans notre monde et bien je vous suggère
tous ensemble d'agir pour l'avènement de
l'économie sphérique et de l'abondance
des usages
merci
[Applaudissements]